first of all welcome to hopefully the
microphone works better we have someone
to make sure that the mics don't squeak
like that anyway our speaker today is
Christopher Hitchens is a contributing
editor of Vanity Fair
mr. Hitchens also writes a column for
the nation and he has informed me that
he this month will have been there or
right had will have been writing that
column now for 16 years
at the nation he also contributes to a
number of other publications he's the
author of several books and perhaps is
best known for his his books that took
critical examinations of Princess Diana
and mother Theresa he is smart
articulate independent and fearless and
as such embodies the virtues that we as
alternative journalist highly value and
he is here today to answer the question
or alternative newspapers doing their
job mr. Hitchens
thank you a chip very handsome
introduction I know that some Jennifer
flowers once entered a Marilyn Monroe
look-alike contest and I feel a bit that
she must have felt following as I do
immediately honest speech and
presentation by sy Hersh who has always
been one of the one of the terms I don't
propose to use today as a role model but
it's always been a real example to
anyone who wants to use the power of
words and language and reason for the
purposes of justice and democracy and
also just for the pleasure of seeing the
wind let out of certain major bags no no
animals will be harmed in the making of
this speech but certain other phrases
will not be used either role model is
one fragile truce I won't say emerging
consensus will not appear bipartisan
agreement I don't propose to lean on
very much either I have a great friend
in Jerusalem called Israel sha who used
to be the professor of chemistry at the
Hebrew University very lucky to be alive
he's very nearly put an end to in Poland
in his youth is the founder of the
Israeli League for human and civil
rights one of the great moral figures of
our time in my opinion I call him up
every now and then say Israel how are
things going he says well it still
sounds polished as well so our
encouraging science of polarization
according quite often IG was living in
Washington often feel I need to be
reminded that that's true the
polarization isn't something to be
feared that polarization and the
dialectic are what clarify things you
often hear people say tending to pour
their doses or perhaps their chins you
know well really some of these things
you've written generate more um more
heat than life it's always a safe thing
to say you know ridiculous bloody thing
to say where do they think light comes
from what is the source of all light
source all right is heat people don't
even listen to the cliches on which they
rely anymore
if they could only hear themselves speak
but of course they don't because they're
pundits they are their transmitters and
not receivers that's half the problem of
all journalism it's particularly a great
problem in this our fair city the
nation's capital now when I first came
to United States which at the end of the
60s I boarded a Greyhound bus and went
all around the country looking for
trouble which was actually easier to
find there know only slightly easier
than to find them it is now it's always
there if you know where to look and one
of the many things that impressed me
about the United States was that uh
everywhere I got off the bus almost
there was what you could call an
alternative newspaper you could pick up
if you were in Atlanta they're great
names to some of them to the great
speckled bird was the one in Atlanta
some of you probably remember it Chicago
rising up angry particularly good one a
paper with attitude the Berkeley
Berkeley Berg the Berkeley barb the East
Village other I don't want to sound
nostalgic there's been there's been a
lot of slightly slushy stuff about the
60s this year but this was for real and
you can tell by its language in its
presentation that it was for real as
well it had a language of anger and
generous anger but real anger and
contempt oh I think the essential
ingredients in the journalistic makeup
one of the one of the hard counterparts
of skepticism it had solid news and it
had a lot of a lot of moxie
I'm not nostalgic for the psychedelic
design I've never been able to read
white on red very easily purple on
yellow things like that but there was
some there were some artistry in there
to those of you who remember the comics
of our crumb for example we'll come to
know them later or remember them from
the time well we'll know that mutant
knew what we saw when we saw them for
the first time that there was artistry
in this movement as well there were
people who really creative and who
really genuinely felt that they'd been
fooled and lied to and exploited and
bullied by the forces of unconstitu tada
thority and really meant to do something
about it did not want to leave lead
their lives that way and knew they
didn't have to no one could make them
now this efflorescence of radical
independent journalism which was
nationwide as well as local and was
connected and coordinated and run by
some very brave people was destroyed as
we all didn't go into a decline it
didn't sink giggling into the sea it
didn't wig out on drugs any of this kind
of thing it was broken up and destroyed
by an organized state campaign waged by
a national political police force the
FBI which had was subjected now then as
it is not now to no constitutional
restraint people were framed on
ridiculous charges sabotage of printing
presses took place blackmail of
advertisers blackmail of distributors
you can read John Wiener once wrote a
very good account what happened how the
how the state took its revenge on on
this independent press and it's worth
reading partly to avoid as I say the
temptations of nostalgia it's also worth
remembering in fact one must never
forget that
what is vacuously referred to by almost
everybody in the press as the war on
drugs and when you hear that this war on
drugs is run by a czar another
uncritically repeated term that is in
the vocabulary of every hat journalist
when you hear it's run by a Tsar you
want to know all there is to know about
it but people say who's the drug czar
these days one which should we have a
new drug czar as if begging for chains
to be laid upon them well if you beg
you'll get anyway that this war on drugs
is the last real vivid present legacy in
our midst of the Nixon years and the
Nixon administration and that it had its
uses in the repressing and for stalling
on foreclosing of dissent now we can't
get there for any of that back and we
can't run on rage and contempt and
obscenity all the time anyway I know
I've tried you can do it quite a lot of
the time but it's it can lead to burnout
I warn you and in the long haul you may
need some other stuff as well but try
and conserve such rage and contempt and
hatred as you can but we ought anyway to
remember and I wanted to try and fix in
our minds for this this meeting the time
when the word alternate
was a really honorable title and dearly
bought and hard-won and bearing some
very honorable scars and we should dip
our flag and pause and salute our
traditions so when I came back to the
United States a few years later I
decided that it was for me and I wanted
to emigrate and I I landed in New York
with my cardboard suitcase and a
promissory note from the Nation magazine
which just as I was going through
customs I noticed hadn't actually been
assigned I didn't mention money it was
the first weekend was the weekend of the
founding conference of the Writers Union
which I attended there was a panel I was
put on with Studs Terkel and Calvin
Trillin among others the studs and blood
sure it was a good baptism of a fire and
some of the lot of discussions were
about what Sam if the independent local
press and somebody got up and said and
they were forgetting he complained that
in his town in upstate New York
I remember I can quote it exactly said
all our readers are being sucked off by
the shoppers and I thought have I come
to the right country or the wrong I
didn't understand the the argot of local
distributive arrangements in those days
but it made me think maybe think then it
makes me think now
and one of the things that makes me
think is this the adage or saying or old
saw or standby silly remark all politics
is local
is one of those platitudes a bit like
think globally act locally incident
you've ever tried that the other way
around ever tried thinking locally
enacting global it makes no more sense
the other way
that's consoling and deceptive and it's
deceptive precisely because it's
consoling it's a trap in other words
just as a lot of national level writing
is done with a very provincial mentality
to it our instance most recently
something I wrote about myself when the
clinton-gore administration would claim
to be taken completely by surprise by
the Indian nuclear explosions and said
well we wish the CIA had told us these
were coming every single journalist in
Washington swallowed it right away never
asking themselves why is it that very
often you find that a government would
rather admit to ignorance so great that
it would be almost impossible then the
contrary which would involve if that
knowledge would be involved admission of
some responsibility
they don't mind looking stupid when the
alternative is looking wicked didn't
even ask themselves could this be true
and of course everyone likes a free kick
at the CIA which is now sort of
authorized okay permitted target so
everyone agreed to write the story
exactly as the White House press office
gave it out it was an intelligence
failure we'll try to do better next time
what if it wasn't an intelligence
failure what if it's true as it takes
two phone calls to find out one phone
call in the case of my friend Nora
Bustani the Pakistani Prime Minister
Nawaz Sharif had written to Clinton six
weeks before those tests personally hand
delivered letter saying mr. president
what are you going to do about India's
impending nuclear test and just to make
assurance doubly sure the Pakistani
Foreign Minister had written to
Madeleine Albright Lee exactly the same
terms on the same day saying we're
gravely concerned about the impending
nuclear tests in the Rajasthan desert
what is the American attitude silence
will seem like acceptance or
indifference well then okay so
ring up we find out some of this too
it's still not in the mainstream papers
so geo confirm you've got those letters
short pause yes okay we did get those
letters well what did you do with them
what would pass them on to the CIA so
that six weeks later they could say the
CIA hadn't told them about the test and
every every journalist in the country
would run with their story it's very
easy to set off a wrong hair and get
everyone to follow it just as any small
town provincial manipulator can do with
some rube press that's what I mean by a
national mentality a natural excuse me a
national national-level story an
international a global story still
covered in a provincial small-town way
and just as I say with this national
level writing done with the provincial
mentality so there's no reason why local
writing can't aspire to be global one of
the great stories of the last year it
seems to me over the last few months in
fact but it's been building for a long
time is that in spite of an announced
congressional cut off on such activity
the United States special forces were
training the Indonesian special military
and political police and it's some
months now since Megawati Sukarnoputri
the leader of the Indonesian opposition
wrote an open letter to our great
president to lead of the free world
saying I should like to know for one
thing against what enemy these troops
are being trained and these special
police forces the Indonesia is
threatened by nobody it has no external
threat invasion it indeed it rather
tends to invade other countries such as
East Timor good question those troops
are being trained for a long time in the
United States and the people who trained
them were being trained for a long time
in the United States that must have been
happening outside somebody's little town
somewhere and it seems to me a shame in
her approach the story was missed was
missed because people we're not looking
for it the stories do not present
themselves there has to be a suspicion
that the government is not on the level
now you have to be able to think of your
own government in your own state as
potentially hostile as perhaps unwilling
to tell or economical with the truth and
you have to keep the powder of your rage
and contempt in a permanently dry
condition it's the same with all writing
as a matter of fact William Faulkner was
able to describe really the whole of the
human condition by
focusing only on a small hermetic
mythical County in in the deep south and
now we have as president and leader of
the free world a uniquely cheap small
town small time character who incubated
his political style over many many many
years in a small state and it seems to
me that newspapers or magazines that
consider themselves to be local and
alternative shouldn't be able to present
us with some early warning clues about
the Clinton narrative the Clinton MO the
Clinton style in the pension one hand
washing the other I went down to
Arkansas myself during that election
campaign to try and see what the
alternative press had on file it was
pretty thin I've got to tell you
and that was it seems to me that's an
intelligence failure we should have had
early warning and here I think the
failure is cultural despite the fact
that the large majority of Americans
live either in major conurbations or in
suburbs and that an increasingly large
number of Americans live in effect in
the international and global economy and
it barely matters what passport they
hold or citizenship they hold as to how
they actually operate there is still a
tremendous cultural lag whereby in
politics a politician feels they must
stress small-town hick roots what sylvia
plath
pulls in the bell jar some
manic-depressive hamlet such as for
example Hope Arkansas or nowhere
Nebraska or wherever it was that Robert
dole claimed to have come from and
rushed back to revisit this small-town
routine is I think this mantra is both
an anachronism and a curse and it brings
with it a petty and unimaginative
mentality and I think it's particularly
incumbent on those who feel that they
are grassroots another phrase that
requires interrogation and is used
always as a as a cliche it always has a
rather warm and fuzzy want to be to be
very much on their guard against this
temptation now I was asked to judge the
prizes of your in a couple of categories
and did do so and I've got some
observations on this too first there are
far too many damn prizes in the
journalistic profession we're much too
keen on giving each other
Awards this happens at all levels of the
trade and radio television and print
it's like party favors or a caucus-race
in Alice in Wonderland everybody's got
to get something no one must feel left
out I think this this is a weed that is
spreading much too much too fast and
prices should be watering much more
sparingly and one of the curses of
course is they have to be awarded every
year it won't be true that everyone
ought to win a prize for journalism
every year if you're wooden every year
it'll mean every year someone gets one
who doesn't really deserve it
and I can tell you in some papers it's
really bad because if you have won a
prize above a certain level you're
practically under fireable and there's a
sort of logjam and clog up further up
the pipe of people who once won a prize
and now cannot be flushed out that's the
first thing there is an upside actually
in my opinion probably quite a lot of
mainstream papers would do no
investigative reporting at all wouldn't
maintain even a team for it if they
didn't think they might get a Pulitzer
who wants to put it so when Murray when
my captain got his I sent him a letter
saying I thought no less of him for
doing so second there was a lot too much
small-time I don't mean small town but
small-time emphasis in the stories at a
time when after all most mainstream
papers if not all are more and more
stressing that they cover the local
stuff that they do the details that they
they're they're out there in the burbs
the LA Times is always saying you know
you we're much better the Orange County
Register at doing the you know the local
story it's not enough just to be local
and third too many of them were written
and this is my main point were written
as if they would like to have been
accepted by the Metro section of a
mainstream paper and indeed could have
been and in fact if I'd had there was
printouts and not on the reprinted page
I could have easily mistaken them for
that now to be alternative you have to
be able to avoid the debased and the
deadening style that the legend
predigested language of the consensus if
you find you've said when you're
investigating some local puke or
national puke questions remain or the
rumors about him which are never rumors
by the way
they're always true and it's always
worse than you suspected if you found
you said these rumors are disturbing
watch the hell out in my opinion it's
just a theory it's only a theory but the
cliches are actually waiting inside the
keyboard for you they're there already
they're programmed in you just have to
put your fingers on and they sleep right
there into the cortex and bang out onto
the paper again they're lurking watch
out for them people stick by you wack
them like snake hit them over the head
don't find that you've said don't find
you've said questions from eight or
friends say but critics charge this is a
great New York Times but I always think
it critics charge with friends say now
back to those greedy swallowing shoppers
by the way before we forget them there's
a lot of criticism of the alternative
press I've read there's a rather
interesting piece in the nation this
week which some of you may already have
read about the state of the alternative
press a lot of criticism for accepting
money for advertisements well whatever
next I was shocked to discover this had
been going on I we wouldn't have put up
with that at the great speckled bird I
think this is just a stupid false issue
raised by pious people have no real
interest in kicking any any bottoms at
all there's no conflict of interest
involved in any way conflict of interest
is not in our society the problem the
problem is the ghastly gruesome
enforceable harmony of interest that
were all expected to feel as if society
was a bloody family and that the whole
than that the whole of America would one
day be one great big enjoyable
Disneyland that's the future that's
being prepared for you and there'll be
no conflicts of interest there you can
bet don't worry about the conflicts of
interest and be proud of the alcohol ads
and the tobacco ads and the sex ads -
you should be proud of during the ads
that no one else wants that's part of
being alternative it would just be nice
if you tried to produce papers that read
more as if they were written under the
influence of these things
what you've got to be on your guard
against is not pressure from the
delinquent ads in other words but from
the respectable ones from normal
commerce and okay received opinion now
here I declare an interest I have a
friend called Dan Perkins known to some
of you as Tom tomorrow who's a very good
cartoonist who shows no interest it
seems to me at all in becoming
domesticated and some of you run him and
more of you should and some of you don't
run him anymore because he ran a rather
witty cartoon and showing that Barack
outlines of a Roman orgy in a which is
his own rather clever adaptation a
reproduction of a classical picture in
order to give his opinion of the The
Washington Lewinsky [ __ ] fest and the
Oklahoma Gazette wouldn't would run it
but its publisher and some people in the
local community wouldn't have it and
here's what the local community leaders
thought Oklahomans for Children and
Families ocf is lucky in having a man
called Bob Anderson as its leader and we
went when asked if the cartoon appealed
to his ProLiant interests you have to be
asked that if you're going to go through
the absurd Radovan tired of testing for
obscenity which you shouldn't do
shouldn't allow the first step of that
inquiry to begin but never mind Anderson
said that it didn't but that he thought
it might appeal to others step by the
way is the definition of pornography
otherwise if that wasn't true the censor
would have to be the most corrupt man in
the country because he would be the one
to be forced to read it and we couldn't
have a corrupt censor now could we but
she thought he mused it might teach a
girl to try oral sex with another girl
or someone might say I haven't tried
anal sex he might turn someone else on
now this deeply distressed and
distressing man
isn't worth a moment's consideration
right
he's absurd and sinister on his face and
needs devoted professional help and some
expensive operations but no he has it
all his own way the publisher healthy of
the paper of the Oklahoma Gazette as a
person called bleakly or Blakely and he
says musing again had I been asked about
writing the cartoon question I would
have said not to run it not because it
was obscene but because a significant
number of our readers would have found
it offensive mistakes in judgment
sometimes occur measure us by how we
respond to the lessons we learn not by
the mistakes we make this is a love
slave right this is getting really
seriously indecent
now because he is a lawyer and because
he has contracts with the school board
and so on I won't give you the whole
story the they'd not just apologize and
grovel if they cry before they've been
hurt and the cartoonist Paul doesn't
look as if the trauma is gonna be in
that paper again I say that's an
absolute disgrace don't be a journalist
if your intention is to be inoffensive
inoffensive is a synonym for innocuous
harmless I risk everything and say
emasculated perhaps I should say
eviscerated whose ambition is it to me
that let them go to another profession
there are plenty of professions in this
great country that welcome such people
journalism is not one of them I think
that everyone should run that cartoon
every every the alternative syndicate
the AMA if it has any meaning should be
enabled to call a meeting of its members
and say everybody runs that cartoon in
solidarity and everyone backs up the
editor and telling mr. bleakly Blakely a
couple of home truths but no you see
there's an easy surrender now if you'll
surrender that quickly
where are you different from any Chamber
of Commerce dominated local newspaper I
think it's a disgrace and I think people
should look into their into their hearts
and their consciousness and see if there
isn't something they could do about it
in contrast that someone is mr. William
furry here I just also wanted mr. Fairey
I wondered if he could be a real person
because you've sounded a bit as if you
could be an ark ROM character
faced with similar pressures in Illinois
he wrote he wrote like this and this is
a bit more like it
he says ironically often the
introduction to a bad sentence
ironically but not in this game Illinois
Times has taken the high road in
covering the sex scandal stories not
once reporting on or commenting aloud or
making light of them since the Monica
Lewinsky story broke in December instead
we let this modern world speak for us
that's Tom's cartoon strap reducing the
whole media circus to a cartoon which is
about as close to the truth is we could
get if that offends you if you are
obsessed with knowing what politicians
are screwing around with whom instead of
which ones are selling the country and
your children's future downriver
perhaps you should crawl back underneath
the rock of mainstream media if you
can't stand the light of day get out of
the Sun Bravo mr. furry very good that's
the words the stuff together
and if I wasn't on c-span I would tell
you a couple of phrases the great
speckled bird with suggestions we would
have made to mr. Blakely as well by the
way also I commend you for saying if you
can't stand the heat get out of the Sun
because the light and the Sun as you
know as I already said heat our lives
are very closely related so let us not
have indicates the great Samuel Clemens
when he said that the great glory of the
country was that it had a first
amendment guaranteeing absolute freedom
of expression and the prudence never to
resort to it intimidation
intimidation should not be that easy in
a country where we are anyway told there
is nothing to fear and we're certainly
nobody who stands up to a local bully
and public opinion is often much harder
to alleged constructive public opinion
is often much harder to face down than a
coalition of advertising interests but
at any rate no one's gonna go to jail
yet for this or lose their job or their
house forever or have their children go
on the streets though we have to
sometimes measure ourselves against the
countries some of them very near to us
some of them intimately affiliated with
our own government where that is the
risk of journalism and try and be worthy
of being called the colleagues of those
people too otherwise there's always the
law but there is some there is quite a
lot of fear in America all the same and
it depresses me or people say well what
are the great causes these days it seems
to me extraordinary that people will say
that that there's no there's no crusade
to undertake when all liberties every
Liberty guaranteed by the Constitution
evaporates right away if you can be
accused of smoking the wrong kind of
cigarette that people go around in fear
also of getting ill of becoming sick or
having any if their loved ones become
sick that without anyone voting on it or
even being a lot of debate on it see if
forthcoming soon to be Parrish major fix
of medicine and spreading terror of
illness across a free country and let me
just tell you there's a local story and
a national story right there in every
town in these great United States or
meekly submitting to being frisked and
are stupid and intrusive questions at
the airport you practically need a
passport now
take an internal flight the United
States and nobody voted for that urine
tests lie-detector tests that can be
imposed on people who work at any moment
my standard here of courage resistance
and Lutheran here I stand defiance is
some fat boy Shultz
George Shultz Secretary of State was
major chairman of the Bechtel
corporation who said he wouldn't take a
lie-detector test and nobody could make
him and he would be ashamed of any
employee who would well I think it would
be reasonable if we set as our standard
of courage and martyrdom and push me no
further than this and don't tread on me
that no one in this room will agree to
be less courageous than the barbers
finger of the former chairman of Bechtel
I think we could all work with that but
I'm not absolutely sure that we can say
that so maybe we should hold our
laughter now alternative means can only
mean either telling people what they
don't want to hear or what they don't
already know it is impossible to find
out in advance for our profession
anything worth hearing from a focus
group it may be true for marketing the
focus grouping works it may be true for
the franchising of our debased political
campaigns that it's good to know in
advance what people want or what people
think but in our profession any
flirtation with polling or focus
grouping is already creative and
professional death because it is our
whole job to tell people things they
don't already know make them feel things
they haven't already felt tell them
things they haven't already heard there
is no way of finding out in advance in
other words what we should be doing
that's why our job is worth it that's
why it's worth a good person giving
their life that's why that must be
resisted anything that anything that has
any trunk with that is by definition not
alternative that's why people
self-employed working for no one in
particular like the great Seymour Hersh
who you just heard all like Washington's
only really serious resident historian
who's Kitty Kelly no I do not jest
someone who really did take on really
went loaded for bear and went for a big
game and brought it down and brought it
home three times on the trot that's not
bad for a lifetime or the late great I
have
who was I'm proud to say a friend and a
mentor of mine who used to say
materializing my point about the
provincial and the National the
Washington Post that's our local sheep I
don't know why they don't give it away
by the way it said is he is AG really
great newspaper you never know on what
page you're going to find the front-page
story well being alternative in other
words is an exercise of the of the
intellect as well as the aesthetic it's
a science as well as an art it's
something you are not something that you
do that's something that you do as well
and the crucial thing is as I say and as
I began by saying not to find yourself
borrowing the stale language of the of
the commercial and the consensus and
being ready at all times to stand
against the healing process being ready
at all times when you hear people say
well we're against the politics of
division to reply but politics is
division by definition being willing in
other words to promote and sow and
spread and celebrate hatred and division
thank you
well I'm all yours
I have no members of the immediate
family here so I you may not think it's
invidious if I recognize questioners but
maybe someone would like to do it for me
well if there are no question as the
questions moot okay that Richard says
okay if I take questions but as I say
not sir
I was asked if there was anything the
government did about which we can feel
in any way comfortable I feel that maybe
a hook somewhere inside that bait but
well actually you know one I discovered
when doing my piece on HMOs that one of
the things about this health service the
health system excuse me a health racket
that leaves nearly 20% of Americans
uncovered that one is surprised to find
conservatives not minding about is that
it it's forcing some people to stay on
welfare because if you are on welfare
you're an automatic Medicaid recipient
and Medicaid is better than quite a lot
of the HMOs now and it's also much
cheaper the government managed to
deliver that service you know it's not
many frills but reasonably efficiently
in effect your income is I think it also
does quite well with the mail I don't
think it's bad that you know for that
for 37 cents over 32 so that we're 32
cents you can get something hand-deliver
at the other side of the country in a
couple of days I think that's good
service what I don't think this may just
show my age I mean it's but it's
probably because of the time when I was
growing up in the 60s what the main
thing that one learned and it's once
you've learned it you know run and it is
that all these people in the in the
ministries and the planning rooms and
the skunk tanks and so on around
Washington don't know any more than you
do they're there they're bluffing
they're getting through the day in the
same way as you are wondering how it's
going to play out they don't they their
power is meaningless and their knowledge
is pretty empty and
County and they should cover this up
they lie all the time
and so how could it be otherwise I mean
how likely would it be that the people
in charge were there because they knew
better than you or were better people
probably very unlikely indeed yet how
much of what they say is repeated on
critically as the news because they say
it was the news the spokesman said
yesterday it's on the front page
well let's make it easier for them if we
can Andy a lot of people who put out
even these papers even alternatives even
who would put out or not put out then
perkins cartoons are concerned about
what kids may see because they could
pick this up at the supermarket with
anyone else you're a father and a
journalist and I wonder if you'd comment
on us constraining or restraining what
we put in the paper because kids might
see it oh yes
first of all did you bring the
Pittsburgh Penguins hockey part Ellen
well in that case I'll give you an
answer a lot too much is done in this
country in the name of protecting
children I mean in other words I think a
lot of grown-up life so to speak is
being infantilized in the name of
protecting children i one of my flags
goes up straight away when I read that
something has to be done to protect the
kid Ewings this is partly from a rooted
objection I have to being treated like
one which is happening more and more
Dwayne jameelah go to the airport
never mind showing a photo ID did you
pack your own bags
I got a chap who does that for me
aha no federal law says it's a it's a
criminal offense to try and be funny at
this point okay well did anyone give you
anything to bring to their for today
yeah just gonna say it's ridiculous and
it's also obvious it's it's clearly
dulling the minds of the people who are
in charge of security it's positively
dangerous yet it's enforceable at law no
and this is all treating adults like
children but not in the name of
protecting the kids but still the
Internet is they want to police the
Internet now it should protect the
children they want to do all kinds of
things to protect the children I say the
hell with it
most the children I know all know
greatly a great deal more than I knew at
their age I get asked questions by my
son that I wouldn't have known to ask my
father let alone dared I'm impressed
I think I think they may have a much
better time than we did
as a result getting rid of certain of
the burdens of innocence and it goes to
the national obsession with innocence I
read the other day that Frank Sinatra's
life was a narrative of America's loss
of innocence the time before that it was
wrote Redford's
film quiz show that testified to the
country's loss of innocence I'm doing a
piece on this America's innocence was
lost in the Civil War in the
spanish-american war in the first world
war and that during the depression at
Hiroshima at Nagasaki in Vietnam by
McCarthyism and at Watergate at least
this is a virginity that grows back with
incredible speed
I'm against the infantilizing and the
presumptions of innocence that go with
it and as a journalist anyway operate on
the presumption of guilt which i think
is the only presumption our profession
can bring to it's labor so I'm as quick
as anyone else to to protest that I have
often wear video stores or news agents
or convenience stores stack the really
rough stuff at children's eye level you
should see me do it I've got people to
move things really quickly and without
threatening to bring in the law that I
would certainly have done it and a law
against that kind of display is easily
enforced or a local ordinance that is
absolutely never what the people who
claim to be speaking for our children
are on about never ever ever ever what
they want is to get Nabokov and Tom
tomorrow that's what they want and
that's what they must not be allowed and
they must not be allowed the first
presumption of their of their onslaught
which is that their real interest is in
protecting the young their real interest
is in why after all why don't they call
for prayer in the trains or prayer on
the stock exchange all right or prayer
in the arm compulsory prayer for the
Armed Forces or in the boardroom
somewhere where if it does any good
which I doubt there I think like holy
water it may not do any good doesn't do
any harm but if it did do any good it
might really come in handy knew they
wanted in the schools why do you think
they've wanted in the schools because
they want a captive audience and they
want an audience they can mold and they
can form and they're not going to be
allowed to have it now we're going to
tell them to to get right out of here
every time we try
so Syracuse New Times that is said it
offers meetings we should be proud of
these sex ads because they're different
nobody else in our market will run them
but yet there seems to be a constant
push to mainstream all this stuff with
the vague thought that if you know if we
just show this the exotic dancers head
the shoulders and stead of their entire
bodies that somehow will get the big
department store ads or something which
never seemed to materialize but how do
you argue against this this continual
mainstreaming the advertising
departments whining I'm gonna write
advertising stories stroking the
advertisers rather than you know really
going out and doing something well this
is their shoppers again isn't it look I
mean I don't think being alternative
doesn't mean you have to say that no
compromise with the readership kind of
thing at all and everybody knows that
there are economics to publishing and
for example the only reason why a lot of
people read what I read is because I
write for now is you're fair okay now
that I never get any bother from the
advertisers but we have a lot of outside
if we never get any bother for we don't
allow any of it at you probably because
we're strong enough we wouldn't know
advertiser word dinner I don't think for
one thing we can turn ads away so
obviously and this is what I meant
earlier burn out in the long haul are
you much more likely to survive if
you're economically sound it's a
responsibility to be solvent in my
opinion if we're going to do journalism
no there's no great virtue to poverty
and indigence I said goodbye to all that
a long time ago and I'm now so richer
how do you know what to do with it all
but my hate is still pure and I think I
don't know I never have conversations
with the advertising people at the old
New Yorker the advertising the part was
on a different floor which didn't
connect by the same elevator they
weren't allowed to talk to each other
in fact if met on the street and a
member of the business division was not
allowed to compliment a New Yorker
writer on a story that was considered a
great breach of etiquette they weren't
supposed to know each other fine as long
as the people in the management
department of the business Robin are
drumming up some money but I insist that
they do that as well as stared at my
face let's get real I therefore I'm
probably not the right one to advise you
about how to strike the balance but I'm
glad to hear you say that you're glad to
run deviant advertisements because
deviance and delinquency are the first
importance as good as what we should be
what if they don't you're putting means
you're doing something right we don't
want your money because you're selling
sex I mean to me I say go out and get
that money and give me a raise yes
you've got me to get it right and I say
that alluding to your remark earlier
that all the rumors are true and they're
worse than you think they are except
that sometimes they're not well I think
I do tend to think that most rumors
about the powerful are true most of them
have proved out in my experience and I
do think we have to operate on the
presumption of guilt it makes me angry
every time people say that says they've
been subject to trial by media there is
no such thing we cannot Supino anybody
okay not gonna be deposed anybody nor
very often can we even when we can to a
press quarters we miss the chance to
cross-examine people and we certainly
can't send anyone to jail
more's the pity so it's masochistic to
worry about trial by media there should
be I wish there was something more like
a court of public opinion in this
country and I have big ideas about who
it should halt in front of itself but
there isn't so it's it's both it's funny
it's both masochistic
sort of partly sadistic to say that
there is when there isn't I think it's
it's creepy in other words if something
is an unsubstantiated rumor then the way
to deal with is as follows use the press
converse to ask the guy they should be
asked okay there a lot of times
embarrassing questions are not asked
because access will be forbidden to the
person who answers that question
it's very common press converses now for
people to say you know if you especially
child of town reporters who may want to
make an impression back here if you ask
will call on you you can ask a question
and you'll be on the 19 years if you'll
make sure it's a friendly one that's
done what they didn't they should
instead use that time to ask the
question everyone's been wanting to know
the answer to it doesn't want to be the
one to ask that's the job okay now
obviously it's pretty - we're we
wearying to go into this business of the
internet and Matt Drudge and so on again
and again but and I don't think Rogers a
journalist I think he's I think he's a
pimp
I think he's sir he's an operative for
undisclosed not very decorative
political interests who simply feed him
a chair he does no digging okay he's
just a conduit they could have and they
very soon will be able to have a cyber
Natasha's version of him they don't need
a human being that's needed the site
they can put their own gunk up there and
submit in circulation and probably they
could invent some kind of truman
character to do it or wag the dog
[ __ ] as a surrogate figure but I have
to say that what he said in the National
Press Club where I don't think he should
have been invited last week was true
that the the speed by which news can
materialize or suggest itself
cybernetically has broken the hold of
the old news cycle and that's a good
thing because it used to be that the
gatekeepers in Washington on all the
newspapers and all the television shows
and chat shows and they would decide
what the news was and if people didn't
want something to be news everyone knew
the White House would put it out in the
Saturday afternoon release and all this
kind of thing and that was all clearly
understood and part of the rules and the
people who did it went and played golf
with the people who put it out and
that's over now they can't do that
anymore they've lost control and there's
some of the things that result from that
are on unpleasant and vulgar I think one
mustn't neglect the outside of it so let
the arbitration of public opinion decide
whether something is true
well I did not join the profession to do
was to know what the rumor is in
Washington and none of my readers know
and keep it to myself
let them arbitrate it let them test its
credibility after a while my thing
Gresham's law could go into reverse
people would would know immediately
watch a discard and what to take
seriously but we can't be the ones doing
that for them we I'm not a filter I'm a
transmitter
I hope you've said earlier that a
divisive nurse and polarization are
valuable because when you have devices
miss that's when issues are clarified
but you also hear pundits who are saying
that people are growing in esta Tyson
complacent and they're tired of hearing
people whine there's a book three years
ago called the culture of complain
everybody's tired of people whining and
also a frequent criticism leveled
against the media's are that the media
is great at criticizing processes and
and ideas but we're terrible prescribers
um first of all do you see American
society growing more complacent and and
two if so do you think there's an
antidote anywhere in sight gosh well was
the question audible to to all because
it would be somewhat difficult to pray
see it's basically it's I mean read
might boil down saying is the press any
any better taking it that it is
auditioning it out would be one of the
your questions I suppose and second what
about some what about the culture in
general has it become more complacent
while yet it's sort of more Charan
complaining it may there may be
something in the latter point I think
because there's no shortage of people
regarding themselves as victims and
that's what Robert Hughes his book was
about the culture of complaining I
thought it was good there's a lot of
self-pity around there's no question
about that but there isn't very much
interest in the predicaments of others
and there isn't I think any belief that
things would get better if anyone really
seriously politically complained the
nerve of outrage seems to me at the
moment to be somewhat dead let's perhaps
more hopefully say dormant I often
wondered what it would take to shock
people into action I mean just it did
seem to me that the the news that in
spite of
a much delayed and overdue congressional
ban on it that Americans were training
with the knowledge of the Defense
Department death squads in Indonesia
ought to have got people annoyed but it
didn't part of it is what we call in
Washington Post Watergate morality it
used to be people didn't believe the
government did this kind of thing they
really didn't believe it they thought
the government was on the level and when
under the surreal sledgehammers of
evidence they found that wasn't true for
a while there was a reform movement in
Congress and in the press and elsewhere
and you know a bit of a housecleaning
after that people got cynical and so
when you told them hey guess what
politicians are openly on sale in
Washington they'd say well so what do
you expect or wake up and smell the
coffee or some other wised up remark as
if who doesn't know that that's quite
hard to mobilize that that mentality
because it's some cynical without being
enraged or hate fueled to meet my to
tassles it is difficult i predict that
there will be a rebellion against the
health exploitation racket in fact it
seems to be already building but there's
an element obviously of self-interest in
there as well as of compassion so we
have to keep up how to drive for better
days that's not really a place for
journalists it made me think of what's
happening what I'm reading about what's
happening and LA Times now was running a
few had written anything about that or I
haven't written anything about the other
times that when I was teaching at the
journalism school in Berkeley earlier
this year we did have the editor up
there he came because we sent him such a
long letter of complaint about the paper
came up and spoke to us actually was
quite interesting he feels his job is to
please okay he wants he wants the
readers to like the paper wants them to
feel at home with it wants it to be easy
for them to read all that kind of thing
you can't I mean it within his own his
own what should we call it his own
universe of discourse he's perfectly
correct I didn't join the profession of
because I wanted to be light okay
nonetheless I've become credibly popular
more friends and I know what to do with
but not by looking not by sort of being
ingratiating I hope you'd be the judge
of that obviously what can he do he has
to sell the papers but I think he feels
that as a lot of people do that it's
best if you can to find out what people
would like now I did I mean see how it
play out so you're having a conversation
with a stranger you've met in a bar on a
plane and you break off to say excuse me
I've been trying for last five minutes
to make a good impression on you would
you mind us telling me if I'm succeeding
or not well this has a long way to go
before its craziness okay but that's the
method that is now the method by which
politics and business and I'm afraid a
large amount of journalism is actually
consciously run I went to a TV focus
group thing in Bethesda at the other
night I was lucky to get a mailer things
say inviting me mr. Chia televiewer it
said I don't watch television you can
shape the future television America is
one of those so I thought must I can't
miss this and they showed us they showed
they've offered us various tampons and
douches and cold sprays and inducements
to watch some terrible I think I made I
think wasn't even faked previews and
then a huge questionnaire on our buying
habits it was it so obvious Oracle but
everyone in the room acted like a
complete zombie and I thought this is
the pornography of the Democrat this is
learning to hate and despise your fellow
citizen this is watching people behave
like absolute cattle I couldn't bear it
they obedient ly did everything the MC
told them to do I hung around at the end
and everyone was outraged they thought
they'd been brought there under a false
pretense they were very critical to
everything that had happened to them the
waste of time they'd never come again
what are they take us for but the
marketing people have walked off with a
huge pile of stupid answers that they
got just by asking stupid questions and
they'll say that's what the people wants
you count on it now you need a certain
fortitude to resist that many people in
their dreams that we've all had that
what do we do and the big test comes as
a journalist you know when the big
squeeze is put on you not to tell the
truth or be brave if you haven't had
this fantasy you would start thinking
about having it
well you think it's going to be you know
the the swag bellied sheriff or the
pot-bellied Tycoon or the great polluter
or whatever it might be but it's much
more likely to be someone saying to you
after work it's great stuff you've been
doing on that series but you know it
isn't really playing the public don't
seem to want that at all people are
bored with this
now you try and stand up against that
but much much more insidious and much
much more to be feared and easily said
by someone who says it's not me it's
just the public seemed not to the dogs
were he did the thing that every dog
cows are like I'm the bad guy who owns
the voice most dreads to hear the
pooches word go for it well there you
are we shouldn't be afraid of that
because we never guarantee people that
what we were going to give them would be
what they like or what they want let
alone that it would reinforce what they
already knew already thought I got a
call from someone who's writing a piece
about it and I was very suspicious I
have to say because I have a feeling
that the wrong people are going to like
it
this is maybe wrong for me to prejudge
it but one of the assumptions appeared
to be similar to the one that Congress
came up with in the form of that
complete popinjay and jerk senator Byrd
former Klansmen and fiddle player who's
a pork staffer for West Virginia and he
said when when it was decided that
congressional and monuments should be
fully disclosed speaking fees and all
that kind of thing which I think they
should he said well then it will
generally should be forced to disclose
what their speaking fees and other you
know other emoluments are and so a lot
of people that seemed like a fair trade
not a bit of it I won't hear a bar of
that ditty this is certainly not from
Senator Byrd actually not from anybody
else neither No well we are not running
for office we don't claim to speak for
anyone else we're not charged legally
with the same responsibilities etc etc
etc it's none of their business
okay we're a different kind of
profession
and I the same would be true for the
attempt made by some people in the
Clinton White House it was aborted but
there was a plan to say well how would
the sex lives of those sort of
questioning the president really stack
up well suppose they've gone ahead with
that plan
which I knew was discussed so what you
don't have to be pure to ask the
question okay because you aren't the one
who's involved in the conflict of
interest or the harmony of interest that
is under investigation I had a feeling
from the way the questioning went from
the sky from Brill's shop that they were
sharing in the assumption that the press
should be investigated okay and that
will appeal to exactly the wrong kind of
instant populism so I'd be on my I'm
very much on my guard against it and I
hope I'm wrong in my suspicions yes just
an observation and a point of criticism
the dog chow guy as you call them helped
me start a paper in Orange County where
we are blessed I think as you put it to
have the LA Times in Orange County
competing against the register neither
of which can seem to understand the
county that they actually operate in
because they're so tied in with the
Republicans and the land developers and
the exploiters of Labor and so I'm
really curious about that so expression
you don't hear enough these days I think
so anything right but I'm curious about
why you think we ought to be satisfied
with the local coverage we get from a
guy like mark Willis who runs the times
when it comes to local issues because
they are they are exactly as you
suggested before the worst elements of
provincial journalism with the worst
aspects of the national this is a huge
multinational corporation that pretends
to be as they put it in their
advertising on our side and yet the side
they mean they're on is this side that's
kicking us in the ass every day yes on
our side isn't it terrible I check for
my pulse every morning to see if it
still pisses me off that the New York
Times has that box saying all the news
that's fit to print and it's every day
it still does
and then I check then I check to see is
the Washington Post still running
horoscopes yup it still is so that I
feel braced for the day you know the the
contempt glands kick in again and on
your side used to be the circuit of
Channel seven here seven on your side
what
horsefeathers I didn't even released me
to suggest you should be satisfied what
I said was it depressed me at a time
when the proud boast of the local major
outlets is how local they are and how
how grassroots and domestic is their
emphasis that so many of the prized
entries I read and I presume that people
were sending me what they thought was
their spark ear stuff could have
appeared in the Metro section of a major
paper without much alteration or perhaps
with none and seem to be written either
under the influence of it subliminally
or perhaps with a view to one day
landing a job there I mean that seems to
me to be depressing a single feature
called the real astrology I'd love to
hear your feelings on that gully well I
think it's probably I think it's not the
most sinister form of current
superstition and we are going to be
facing a tsunami of of nonsense of this
kind as the millennium gets nearer I
think of Nostradamus Recycling's and all
kinds of burbling from the beyond and
all kinds of that thing
but but astrology is I think the most
feeble-minded at the superstitions and
sinister only in the sense that it's the
most solid Cystic just as the religious
fool believes that he is the object of
God's creation and was create you know
it's so loved and created for purpose
and even supervised to all the time
that's how much he counts and by the way
this is what's known as modesty among
Christians I don't understand it
but I can see why they call themselves a
flock all right the fact is that it's
been discovered a long time ago that not
only is the universe not man-centered it
isn't even earth centered it isn't even
Sun centered it probably doesn't go
around anything very much
obviously the solipsists and the
narcissists and the falsely modest are
depressed to find this so much better to
think that a star map that was drawn
before Neptune Pluto and Uranus were
discovered has the remaining planets
orbiting to find out what your chances
are getting laid
I would not i certainly if i was i would
i would never refuse an advertisement of
any kind and i have stone in his weekly
was always very firm about that he never
took outs didn't want them but he would
always criticize even his favorite local
papers if they did refuse objection with
harassment i think it's a matter of
principle i don't think i don't agree
with the Buckley Supreme Court decision
on political money as given being First
Amendment exercise I think that's
obscene but I think advertising his free
speech so but I wouldn't run an
astrology column
I just wouldn't and I remember when um
police stream paper where I work once a
night since I've done a lot of work at
the yellow end of the trade in my time
and I dare say that it shows it was
decided to fire the astrologist and I
was wished I was the editor who wrote
the sacking letter which began as you
will no doubt her force
flea stream was very heartless place in
this day
that's how I get rid of mine if I have
inherited knows how to play yes the
mainstream press and especially the
dailies and the TV stations are very
much a part of this harmony of interest
you've talked about along with the
chambers of commerce and the developers
in the government why shouldn't the
deals they make and what they accept for
the sharing of their wisdom and from
whom be subject to some scrutiny as well
and is alive the papers here mine
included do press criticism and do take
a great interest in that kind of
information and think it's a value to
share with people sure there's this is
this about the brill business you mean
or if brew is gonna do that then time
but I have a feeling will I'm sad about
about not wanting to hear a bar of the
ditty about what what journalists take
who they take it from what they're
speaking fees are in a larger in a
broader sense than what do you think of
James Fallows consider what he'll give
you an example I did a thing with James
fellows on on PBS Frontline during the
last election about the press and the
election how it covered it and he had
his critique which was the press is
overpaid it takes too many outside
speaking engagements he particularly
went after Stephen Cokie Roberts and he
fired Roberts from US News this basis
and ABC if that's what she works for
stopped miss Roberts from going to so
many gigs and I had my take on why the
press was covering the election badly in
my take actually was that you could
never make an honest confrontation with
the political money racket since all
that political money is raised to be
spent on the media after all they didn't
raise it to keep it they raised it to
give to the to the to the mass media so
that that's why there was a real problem
and one of the problems to but there was
also problem with the language and the
assumption that we made that the
primaries were really primaries that the
conventions were conventions when they
were media events set up only to please
the profession and therefore it was
wrong to complain that they were
theatrical and staged to us it was at
the behest of journalism that was done
Ted Koppel wanted a non-controversial
smooth convention in San Diego when he
got it he walked because there was
nothing to cover but that's an irony
okay now so I don't care if Cokie
Roberts goes to
the National Association of what known
and gets some money on the side I
wouldn't mind if she kept it a secret
but if you can keep such an appearance a
secret and Jim Warren of the Chicago
Tribune has done a very good sort of
count of all that it's worth knowing but
the other day the Promise Keepers came
to town and there was a big to-do about
it and they're now for once I watched
the show the next day that discussed it
and it was the one that Roberts and
Donaldson are on and someone said well
it looks like this people have a
political agenda they went back and
forth about what it meant The Promise
Keepers and they you know they're not
just here to be good good guys but they
have this agenda of patriarchy and
fundamentalism and Cokie Roberts who is
anchoring it as I remember said well but
they just say Sam although it was that
they've come here to witness and be and
be better people and I just say we
should take them at their own face value
you know out of fired her for saying
that not because of what I think about
The Promise Keepers but because a very
good definition of what a journalist is
not is someone who says you take the
phenomenon in its face value court
rather said okay how much money you've
taken from your fired
okay walk pack you're out of the
building by the end of today you are not
in our profession anymore yeah a bit but
now that C is never that is never going
to be attacked that's fine
the top of the news is what the press
spokesman said yesterday fine no one's
going to be criticized for watching as a
megaphone or stenographer for frauds or
professional liars anyway people who
come on to tell you that they're trying
to put the best face on things then you
say what they say is literally the news
no that's where the problem is the other
stuff is all a distraction and there's
no reason why I mean I go a long way
with then by dick you know and and Mark
Miller and the other people who've
written about the extreme conglomeration
of ownership and so but nonetheless
there is no reason why person working in
those media can't write and produce a
perfectly decent story or item if they
have any any guts at all okay that there
was not used that as their excuse for
not doing it but the but a lot of
tabular miss produced by people are
under no pressure to do it there
cannot make you be a megaphone okay
that's what you have to you have to
police yourself not other people in
other words that's what I'm saying and
watch for the cliche account and the and
watch for the consensus level in your
bloodstream and all that really watch
out because it can kill you yes this
group several years ago what did you say
do you know probably a lot of money so
that's the kind of organization applied
anyway but I I think you made a very
good point about awards being party
prizes and tomorrow the orgy of
self-congratulation here will be
indicative of that my question to you
though is you say matt drudge shouldn't
have been invited to the National Press
Club as if it is as as if the National
Press Club was a sacred institution look
at the membership of the National Press
Club look at the hacks that are in the
National Press Club why in the world
shouldn't Matt Drudge be invited well
actually you're quite right I shouldn't
have I shouldn't have put it it was
pompous of me to put it in that way
here's every right to be their body fit
in like nobody's business I think it was
wrong to invite him as that Joseph he
was a journalist as a phenomenon perhaps
no it's terrible I mean the National
Press Club and really what irritated me
was that they continued with him there
to have the practice of not know no live
questions no one getting up and saying
hey you but write him down pass them
along the table to the chairman who paid
stating he reads them out in this
deferential way that gives any natural
advantage to the platform and is
incredibly easy to to manipulate by any
speaker I mean I last time I went to one
of those lunches was because I was
working for of Maxwell at the time paper
called the European that he owned and he
was the guest of honor so I was invited
to the head table and he was suing the
New Republic at that point because of
the thing Tom Bauer had written about
his scummy dealings but they max what
was any
suing the New Republic as published in
London but not in Washington because the
British libel law because I'm not easier
to sue in England this you probably know
so I thought well I can't live with
myself but I don't do some things I
wrote I've had to write down my question
and I said dear mr. Maxwell if you're
going to sue that you were public just
published in Washington why don't you
sue it here and not in London and what
what's your problem with that and signed
it and the person at the of the chairing
the lunch said okay we guarantee to ask
him that since your head table guess and
so on so I was really interested to see
what he'd say
a lot of dull questions were asked what
of gel answers with Julie given my
question didn't come up I said to the
chairman afters what was so what about
my question said general as this guy
saved the Daily News and he's our guest
he's a job creator we can't be mean to
him well that's the ethos of the Press
Club so as that's it's that sort of
thing that allows people like Raj to
spring up like weeds I expect so I
accept your correction sir feeling a
little bit disappointed because that I'm
not sure you you you've you've nailed
the question that we were sold that is
you know are we worth the are we here
sitting you're worth the paper were
printed on how do you assess what we do
well I don't read you all that I told
you what I read of the of the prize
entries and in a recent piece I did on
the state of collapse of Washington DC
which I said was not is a great local
story but it's the nation's capital so
it's a national scandal and tried again
with my trope about this it is to do
with small town corruption and small
town mentality and graft and thug a
police thuggery and filth and
incompetence and so on but it is a
national disgrace but that it's
supervised by Congress in a
disenfranchised town and I did say there
that I thought that the city paper done
a very good job in staying on Barry's
case all along whether was there was
always a temptation succumbed to by The
Washington Post particularly in the
early years to think of him as perhaps
deserving of a free pass because he was
black for example or at least some
indulgence some slack
they never succumbed to any of that and
I thought that was good
so but if I came to say if you saw the
sign saying Kris directions will appear
at two o'clock and give credit where it
is due
I imagine the room would be half empty I
certainly hope so
one more I'm told and most of it has
focused on Y&R she and her now ex legal
team would have made the decision to go
forward the question I have is why on
earth is vanity fair running those
photographs and you're talking about
pandering to the common common tastes
what decision process do you think went
into that well you are addressing the
author of the accompanying text
and and when you read it you also want
you to know I wrote all the captions
okay as well as the sign bit every word
on that page is by me including the
unsigned bits and I had to say to mr.
King the other night on his show that I
thought my long-held theory that one
word is worth a thousand pictures needed
some consideration I thought some
attention should be paid to the text
that there because that explains a lot
of the answer to your question he that
he he consented to read out a couple of
I thought rather well turned sentences
what was my astonishment that when he
said but Chris he calls me Christmas I
can't bear I always call it mr. King I
don't know the guy that's another thing
by the way people who go on Nightline
and say Ted again you already know no no
no no it's all very bad the journalistic
habit of referring to celebrities by
their nicknames Oh Jay died all that
very Olly
very bad rot real rock critizing rot
spreads like wildfire he said but but
Chris this is you'll have to me this is
celeb dumb I was flabbergasted I was on
Larry King say that celebrity should not
be discussed I didn't know what I didn't
quite how to handle it I think like I
said I chose my words I hurt with care
and I said well yes I think she
qualifies and then I said I didn't come
on Larry King to run down the idea of
celebrity surely but what I should have
said and it occurred to me afterwards
area upon say was that celebrity as we
use it pejoratively or mockingly is
means someone who's well known just for
being well-known ok the original
definition of Daniel Boorstin
when he wrote his famous essay on the
non-event the media event the media
created event the thing that wouldn't
happen if there were no cameras there
Monica Lewinsky seems to be is annoying
that category she is a major player it
may be to a large extent inadvertent
though there are certain things I don't
think you can do without knowing you're
doing them or by app or by accident or
passively
and she has changed the course and
shaped American politics and made you so
more yet so the fact that we've
subsisted until now in a very meager
diet of mug shots and old pictures taken
from her ID cards and so on it seemed to
me a shame it was a good thing to get
the square look at her and we beat the
whole national press on that now you
wanted to know how this decision was
taken well I actually don't know all of
it but I know that someone approached
Ginsburg one of our one of our writers I
believe it was and said what about it
you know and he or whoever has a
reputation to uphold is one of the great
comic characters of this decade said
yeah why not it would do a good to have
a day out Herb Ritts and we said okay
we'll get your Herb Ritts we'll get him
out of the public's as a real artist
with a camera we'll get your mallet we
will do a shoot two lawyers came
including one of her current ones daddy
came they watched it all and they signed
the model release form we thought all
our birthdays had come at once
but it meets my deaf it beats my
definition of news and she certainly is
not she's not a celebrity like my car
would be invidious to think of an
example but she's not a celebrity she's
well known for more than being famous I
think you'll find so I think we did a
bang-up job I really do and see what you
think about the text
it says it goes to the note about rates
point it says that apparently the
national consensus is now that what to
adults do in the privacy of their own
Oval Office
is none of the public's business think
about that that's where we're at that's
where we're comfortable that really is a
D politicized society that believes that
and it's that the society this D
politicized must have been very badly
served by its journalistic profession it
seems to me thank you very much for
coming
thank you very much mr. Hitchens and I
should regarding that Cokie Roberts
issue first of all I'm happy to confess
that she was hired by this group before
I was hired so it was not my decision